لن نتراجع موقف في جمله ترددها موسكو
وتكررها على مسامع حلفائك في الحرب
الدائره والحروب الموازيه لنيه لتغيير
الخطط العسكريه في اوكرانيا اكد الكريم
محذرا من ان روسيا لا تستبعد اي خيار للرد
على العقوبات خيار التحالف الوثيقي مع
بيلاروسيا في زمن الحرب يترجم بافعال تثير
حافظته حلف شمال الاطلس والاتحاد الاوروبي
وكل الداعمين لاوكرانيا وهذا فيديو نشرته
وزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيه يظهر مقاطع
لتدريبات تضم وحده دفاع جوي بانظمه صواريخ
تور المتقدمه من روسيا التوقيت رساله اخرى
غير مشفره بعد يومين فقط من اعلان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين عن خطط لنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا كشف حينها عن جدول
زمنيين لتلك الخطوه المستهجنه من الغرب
اعتبارا من الثالث ابريل المقبل ستبشر
روسيا تدريب الفرق وفي الاول من يوليو
ستبني مستودعا خاصا للاسلحه النوويه على
اراضي بيلاروسيا
بالنسبه لموسكو هذا رد على اعلان لندن
تزويد اكياس بذخائر باليورانيوم المنظم
الهدف من الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا واحد
اوضح وزير الخارجيه
بتقديم دعم واسع مالي وعسكري وسياسي لنظام
كياب المجرم الغرب يقوم بذلك لهدف واحد
ومهمه اعلن عنها هي الحاق هزيمه
استراتيجيه وتدمير الاقتصاد الروسي وخلق
حاله من عدم الرضا لدى السكان على خلفيه
سوء الاوضاع وبالتالي زعزعه الاستقرار
الداخلي
موقف وزير الشؤون الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بولندا بشان ازمه الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه بدم هادنا مقارنه بردود الفعل
التي اعقبت اعلان بوتين قال الوزير شيمونس
ان على الغرب التزام الهدوء في رده على
قرار روسيا نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا واضاف ان القرار الروسي هو عنصر
تصعيد ويجب ان يكون رد الفعل هادئا لكن
حازما
على الارض مزيد من المعارك والدمار
والضحايا في جبهات بخموت وخركيف ودنيتك
وخلصون
يقول كل طرف انه كبد الاخر خسائر فادحه
هنا وهناك في اوكرانيا وروسيا جنازات قتل
الحرب حرب في ابعادها وتداعياتها وتعدد
اطرافها عالميه حتى وان تفادى الجميع
اعتمادها الوصف